-Thank you for coming back
to the show.
-Thanks for having me.
-Every time you come,
you always have a good --
a fun Met Gala story
or some fun story to tell me.
-I do.
Well, it's 'cause
it's about Cher.
-If it's about Cher,
you came to the right place.
-Really?
Do you love her as much as I do?
-I love Cher.
-Okay, so I was at the Met Ball.
Cher was the musical guest
and nobody knew.
-Oh, it's a secret.
-It was a secret.
-Secret Cher.
-And then out she comes...
-Yes.
-...and she's dancing
around the stage in the same --
what looks to be the same outfit
from "Turn Back Time."
-She looked phenomenal.
-It was, like, bananas, right?
-Yeah, she looked phenomenal.
-Cut to her, she's --
Cut to her
singing across the stage.
-Yeah-huh.
-And I'm like
hand up in the air,
waving around.
And she sees me,
walks right to me,
and grabs my hand.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
And I mean like,
it was a personal --
'Cause we're friends, you guys.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh...
-Like, I don't -- yeah, no.
-What?
-Yeah.
-You're friends with Cher?
-Totally.
[ Laughter ]
-You're such a good actor.
-Well, I had a light-switch
plate cover that
was in my bathroom in
my apartment for a LONG TIME...
-Did you really?
-...that was from
the first concert I ever went
to, which was a Cher concert.
-She picked you out
and found you?
-She literally saw me,
and she was like...
♪ Turn back time ♪
-No, she did not do --
-And then she saw me.
"Hey, hey."
It's not great.
-She did not go...
♪ Turn back time ♪
-♪ Time-uh ♪
♪ Time-uh ♪
-♪ Turn back time-uh ♪
-♪ Time-uh ♪
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I have a video of you
freaking out,
if you don't mind me
showing this.
-You have a video?
-Yeah.
Here's the video of Sarah
freaking out watching Cher.
This is real.
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers ]
♪♪
-Oh, my God!
What?!
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I was like, "What?!"
-"What?!"
-"What?"
-Uh, anyways --
-♪ I found someone ♪
-Uh, well, I heard --
We have to talk about...
[ Laughter ]
..."Abominable."
-"Abominable."
-Okay, great.
-You are a voice
in that animated film.
-Which I've never done before,
which is totally scary.
'Cause usually when
you're acting with a person,
you're engaging with them.
-Yeah.
-When you do
a voice-acting thing,
-You're basically in a booth
with no one.
And everyone is always like,
"It's so great.
You don't have
to put on clothes.
You can wear your pajamas
to work."
And I'm just like,
"I want to be in a costume.
And I want to" -- You know.
-Yeah, I mean, I like
wearing clothes, yeah...
-Yeah, what I wear at night...
-...when I work.
-...is like nothing, so...
[ Laughter ]
Well, I'm just saying.
[ Cheering ]
-Oh, my goodness.
-I'm just saying.
-You don't wear, like,
a flannel nighty?
Like a --
-No.
Like a onesie with feet
and everything.
-Yeah.
-You should think about that.
-I'm gonna.
-They're breathable.
-With a little flap that...
[ Laughter ]
-But then, "Goldfinch."
-"Goldfinch," yeah.
-I mean, walk me through this.
Because this is like --
This is a --
People are surprised --
-Yeah. I don't know if you guys
have read the book.
It's a beautiful book.
-I tried.
[ Laughter ]
-800 pages is just too much
for you, right?
-It is beautiful and great.
And I go, "I get it."
And then it turns -- then it
went into a different story,
and I go, "What happened?"
[ Laughter ]
It's all right.
Well, we can cut this out.
-Okay, we'll cut that part out
where it sounds
like it's not good.
-No, it is really good.
I really got into it.
I go, "Oh, yeah.
The museum, the whole thing."
They go,
"It's not even about that."
-It's really not about that.
And I don't come into it
till the part that it's not
about that you're clearly
not interested...
-There's like four chapters
about the museum.
-That's true.
-It's not about a museum.
-So I read four chapters
that's not about anything,
and I'm like,
"What am I gonna do?
This book..."
And you know what I said?
-"I'm not reading it."
-"Can't wait for the movie
to come out."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm really excited."
'Cause everyone who read it said
it's one of the best books
they ever read in their life.
-It is.
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah, no.
-Oh, no.
-No spoilers.
I'm gonna read it
before the film comes out.
-Oh, you are?
-Yeah, when is it coming out?
-It's out now.
-Yeah, I can't read it.
[ Laughter ]
-It's out. Right now.
-Right now, yeah.
What can we say about the film
that we haven't said?
-Well, you said
nothing about it.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I haven't read it,
so I don't really --
I don't quite know
what it's about, yeah.
-Yeah, no.
-The beginning
has nothing to do with the end.
-That's right.
-There you go.
-The movie spent -- the story --
Mm.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
I didn't read it, either.
-Oh, my gosh!
Oh, my goodness!
-I'm kidding!
I'm kidding.
-No, I know you are.
-I love this book.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-And I love this movie.
-Okay. Yes.
-You got to see it.
-Goldfinch is a bird, right?
-"Goldfinch" is a famous
painting that hangs in the Met.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I had that written down there.
-I'm gonna tell all your fans...
-So "Goldfinch" is --
-"Goldfinch" is a painting.
-I go to The Met all the time.
-Do you?
-I go, "Get out of the way.
I want to see 'Goldfinch.'"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I stand there,
I go, "There it is.
Oh, my gosh.
Do you believe what this is?"
-"Out of the way!"
-"Everybody move!"
-"Everyone move, move, move!"
-"I gotta see the 'Goldfinch'!"
-"What is the problem?"
"Take your headsets off.
Go to the other room.
Time for Jimmy
to see 'Goldfinch.'"
[ Laughter ]
Now, "Goldfinch."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't want to spoil it
for anyone.
-No, you couldn't possibly
spoil it
'cause you don't know
what's happening.
[ Laughter ]
-What I can --
I almost imagine it is...
-Sure.
-...a child goes to a museum
to go see "Goldfinch."
-Yes, he does, with his mother.
-Yes, with his mother.
-And on that day...
-Something happens.
-...terrible thing happens
in the museum.
-In the museum.
-He loses his mother.
-That's correct.
-Right.
-And that's where --
-And that's when
the story begins,
which is when you decided
to close the book.
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "Oh, no, no, no.
No, no, no. Nope."
-"I thought it was gonna be
a museum drama."
-"I thought it was the thing
about the 'Gold--' I am out.
I thought this was about people
desperate to see a painting."
-Yeah.
-And actually, nope.
-"Now it's about human emotion."
-"Mom's dead, and I gotta go."
-"I -- Yeah."
-"I got to go."
-So this is all about
his kind of --
-His journey.
-His journey in life.
-And something happens
with the painting
on the day
of this terrible thing
where he ends up
having this painting.
And then maybe someone tries
to take the painting from him.
-Oh.
-Whoa.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
Did we say too much?
-Might have, yeah.
-Yeah, okay, yeah.
-Gave away the plot, basically.
[ Laughter ]
You know, yeah.
-Do you guys want to hear
the plot, or you don't care?
[ Cheers ]
-I don't know...
-All right, well,
we can't say much about the plot
except that, if you want to --
d-If you want to watch
Ansel Elgort and you want to see
Nicole Kidman and you want
to see Jeffrey Wright,
from "Westworld,"
and you want to see
me in a bikini, then I think you
should probably watch --
-Yes, here we go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's a clip of Sarah Paulson
in "The Goldfinch."
Take a look at this.
-Hey, buddy.
Long time no see.
-Hi.
I'm Xandra.
With an "X."
-So we just got into LaGuardia
about two hours ago.
I'm out in Las Vegas now,
and, uh...
Well, things are pretty
different for me, and, uh...
Son, we're straight off
the plane, and, uh...
Well, we wanted to see you
straightaway, of course.
But, also,
need the key to the apartment.
Yeah, I'm here to start
taking care of stuff.
-You should be proud
of your pops.
51 days sober.
-I guess I should've called,
but, well, I figured
it was easier
just to come and get you.
-Get me?
-Sarah Paulson, everybody.